the force of the impact
ripped apart these carriages
tearing and twisting the metal like a
tin can
the train was carrying nearly 500 people
at the start of a long holiday weekend
as it sped through the tunnel
dozens were pronounced dead at the scene
this is taiwan's deadliest rail accident
in decades
[Music]
this was believed to be the cause of the
derailment a construction vehicle parked
on a slope above the railway line
it slipped down from the work site and
hit the train
i was sitting on the aisle seat and i
was thrown to the floor
some survivors managed to walk out of
the tunnel along the top of the train
others had to be carried out
dozens received treatment at nearby
hospitals but the crumpled carriages
inside the tunnel made it difficult for
rescuers to reach those still trapped
more than 150 personnel were working at
the crash site
the trailer of the construction vehicle
slid off the road and crashed into the
train
now the whole head of the train is
damaged
the derailment happened on taiwan's
mountainous east coast a popular tourist
destination
especially as people left the cities
ahead of the tomb sweeping day holiday
taiwan's president cying wen said in
response to a train derailment in
hualien taiwan
our emergency services have been fully
mobilized to rescue and assist the
passengers
and railway staff affected we will
continue to do everything we can to
ensure their safety
in the wake of this heartbreaking
incident
everyone on the train has at least now
been accounted for
this is a day of immense grief for
taiwan
[Music]
the focus next will be on how this
terrible accident
was allowed to happen tom cheshire sky
news beijing